i'm michelle killing annual president of
the montreal economic institute the
public policy think-tank
we have a total of nine columns in
different mainstream newspapers so we
have a potential outreach each week of
9.6 million Canadians so we can work
both on the climate of opinion
broadly speaking through the media but
also with policymakers and the specific
policies that they craft regarding
healthcare in the healthcare system
in economically developed countries the
vast majority of the population will not
be willing to say here's someone who
needs critical care of health care and
for whatever reason he has not saved
enough okay or he's not covered enough
and so tough luck you know we're in a
free society you just had to take care
of yourself or go to the private charity
and if you can't you know well tough
luck you'll die the majority of the
population will think that if there is
someone who's affected by a curable
disease that could put his life in
danger and this person doesn't have the
private means to take care of himself
that there is some sort of government
mechanism of some sort that will take
care of him that I think that's just the
political reality so once once you've
established that that this is that this
is how it's going to be how do you
entice and facilitate more private
charities how do you find more and more
private solutions but organize in a way
that does cater to the fact that we
don't live in societies that will allow
our fellow citizens to die from curable
disease just because they weren't able
to properly manage their own personal
affairs now as far as expenses the fact
that the American system is
quote-unquote more expensive than the
Canadian system well then to that I
answer you know that a Mercedes is
indeed more expensive than it to you
Carola there are certain types of help
treatment that are only available to
their richest people but because they're
available and because you have people
that are willing to pay for those
treatments then eventually they'll
become more economical and the whole
world will benefit from it so I say
thank God that the US has a more
expensive system because it's the whole
world who will benefit from it
eventually that being said I mean do you
guys have problems of third-party
payments you guys have problems you know
of over coverage that is dictated
through political lobbying you know that
forces viagra pills to be available for
free for people who are thirty years old
and want to buy a health coverage these
are policy problems that jack up the
price of your overall system for the
wrong reasons but you also have
top-notch care that also jack up the
total prices but in that case you know
it's perfectly justifiable and it's
actually a very good thing both for
Americans and for mankind
you